bonjour je vous propose d'écouter une
série d'auditions de la mission
d'information sur la réforme des rythmes
scolaires une mission demandée par les
sénateurs ump qui juge que cette réforme
des rythmes scolaires
mécontente tout le monde alors je vous
rappelle que cette réforme est entrée en
vigueur en partie à la rentrée 2013 dans
près de 4000 commune elle vise à mieux
répartir les heures de cours sur la
semaine et je vous propose donc
d'écouter une série d'auditions de
représentants de syndicats d'enseignants
et de parents d'élèves
nous commençons aujourd'hui une série
d'auditions groupe et d'organisations
représentatives toujours dans le cadre
de nos auditions relatives à la mission
commune d'information sur la réforme des
rythmes scolaires
nous avons souhaité cette formule
d'audition collective pour nourrir un
dialogue fécond propice à la réflexion
par l'enrichissement mutuel des
différents points de vue notre première
audition nous permettra d'écouter les
représentants des enseignants et des
inspecteurs de l'union nationale des
syndicats autonomes et les représentants
de l'enseignement public et de
l'enseignement privé de la fdt sont avec
nous ce jour monsieur stéphane crochet
secrétaire national du syndicat des
enseignants et madame laetitia barrel
déléguée nationale messieurs patrick
roumagnac secrétaire général du syndicat
de l'inspection de l'éducation nationale
et franck mutuelle secrétaire général
adjoint premier degré nous avons
également avec nous ce jour monsieur
frédéric sève secrétaire général du
syndicat général de l'éducation
nationale et monsieur joël bon enfant
secrétaire national également messieurs
bruno lamour secrétaire général la
fédération formation et enseignement
privé et alain de boot secrétaire
national je vous remercie d'avoir bien
voulu accepter cette invitation
je vais donner la parole successivement
à chaque organisation pour qu'elle nous
présente son point de vue sur la réforme
et le cas échéant ces propositions quant
à la mise en oeuvre
je demande à chaque organisation de ne
pas excéder dix minutes de présentation
de manière à laisser place aux questions
de madame le rapporteur des sénateurs et
éventuellement débat sachant que nous ne
pouvons excéder deux heures de temps de
débat et de présentation puisque ensuite
nous recevons les associations
représentatives des parents d'élèves
voilà donc dans l'ordre des
présentations je vais à présent vous
donner la parole donc monsieur crochet
et madame barrel madame la présidente
madame le rapporteur mesdames messieurs
les sénateurs
nous vous remercions tout d'abord de
cette invitation est donc bon je vais
donc ouvrir cette cette première ce
premier tour de parole sur cette réforme
des rythmes scolaires
pour le se-unsa cette réforme poursuit
deux objectifs deux objectifs soutenu
pour le parlement une simple
le premier objectif c'est une réforme
qui permet d'avoir une semaine scolaire
qui comprend cinq matinées plutôt que
quatre essais cinq matinées sont
propice aux apprentissages des élèves et
notamment aux apprentissages des élèves
les plus fragiles donc par ce premier
objectif
le se-unsa soutient cette réforme le
deuxième objectif de cette réforme est
de d'ouvrir de nouveaux espaces autour
du temps scolaire en ouvrant des tempes
perry éducatif des temps éducatif
supplémentaire pour tous les élèves
et là aussi c'est nécessaire pour les
élèves issus des milieux les plus
défavorisés
deux objectifs qui font donc que cette
réforme est jugée favorablement par le
se-unsa
il n'empêche pour autant que c'est une
réforme difficile à mettre en oeuvre et
ses difficultés pour le se-unsa il faut
les regarder en face
pour pouvoir les dépasser une à une
la première des difficultés c'est
sûrement qu'elle vient bousculer une
organisation de l'école une organisation
de l'école qui a plusieurs de multiples
décennies derrière elle et donc vient
bousculer les représentations des uns
des autres sur le fonctionnement de
l'école jeudi des uns des autres que ce
soit les enseignants mais aussi les
parents d'élèves les collectivités
d'abord avec cette réforme les horaires
de chacune des écoles ne seront plus les
mêmes d'une école à l'autre
ensuite les horaires d'une journée
d'école à l'intérieur de la même école
peuvent être différents d'un jour à
l'autre
l institut intempéries éducatif qui
n'est pas la charge l'éducation
nationale mais qui a vocation à s'ouvrir
à tous les élèves et qui vient se
positionner sur des créneaux qui étaient
les anciens créneau de l'école c'est
localement que tout se décide dans cette
réforme des rythmes scolaires dans
l'organisation concrète que l'on mettra
en oeuvre sur le terrain il y a dans les
premières difficultés qui se posent
d'abord les difficultés d'appréhension
du texte de qu'est ce qu'il est possible
de faire pour les acteurs concrets de
terrain qui ont imaginé une nouvelle
organisation propre leur territoire
il y a d'abord à s'approprier ce que
l'on a le droit de faire ce que l'on
peut faire est dépassé les
représentations les ondes il et on croit
que et pour l'ensemble des partenaires
qui sont multiples autour de la table
c'est une première difficulté
autre difficulté c'est la multiplicité
des partenaires
il faut donc du temps pour s'entendre
la difficulté multiplicité des
partenaires c'est évidemment les
enseignants les collectivités les
parents d'élèves mais aussi alors là
multiplient la multiplicité des
collectivités qui peuvent avoir à
intervenir sur l'organisation que l'on
imagine à imaginer c'est évidemment la
commune mais aussi la communauté de
communes le conseil général pour les
transports scolaires puis parfois
quelques syndicats intercommunaux qui
ont la compétence sur tel ou tel champ
parmi les les difficultés qu'il faut
qu'il faut dépasser
il faut il faut il faut dépasser les
représentations que l'on de ce que l'on
croit pouvoir faire et ne pas s'empêcher
d'imaginer de nouveaux fonctionnements
il faut sortir des il faut sortir des
modèles des modèles préétablis sortir de
ce qu'on connaît et c'est relativement
difficile évidemment parmi les
difficultés on sait qu'on a une
difficulté autour du cou notamment
autour des temps péri éducatif mais
aussi une difficulté de ressources
humaines il faut il faut beaucoup de
monde pour pour mettre en oeuvre cette
réforme des rythmes scolaires et enfin
du point de vue des enseignants cette
réforme des rythmes vient d'acter leur
organisation du travail et même leur
organisation du temps personnel
et j'y reviendrai un petit peu plus tard
dans les préconisations que nous
pourrions avoir à faire dans une
profession largement féminine aller sur
son lieu de travail cinq jours par
semaine
nécessite de s'organiser aussi du point
de vue de sa vie personnelle pour autant
donc beaucoup de difficultés adp a
identifié puis à dépasser mais aussi des
premiers éléments que nous pouvons
observer après quelques mois de mise en
oeuvre
nous nous garderons bien de tirer des
leçons ou même de faire des
préconisations ou des bilans
contenteront de de faire état de
d'éléments d'observation de témoignages
souvent la construction est difficile
pour que les partenaires arrivent à
s'accorder sur ce que devra être
l'organisation de l'école la mise en
route au moment de la rentrée est
compliquée puisqu'elle vient bousculer
des fonctionnements établi depuis
longtemps on a vu aussi que l'école
maternelle devait avoir une attention
toute particulière
trop souvent on a imaginé des modes de
fonctionnement pour l'école élémentaire
que l'on a conjugué ou dupliquées pour
l'école maternelle et les enfants ne
sont pas les mêmes les les nécessités ne
sont pas les mêmes mais aussi de
premiers témoignages positifs de la part
de nos collègues
cette semaine de quatre jours et demi
avec des après midis raccourci amène des
v1 climat scolaire apaisée dans les
échos là
davantage de temps d'apprentissage
efficaces avec les élèves des temps péri
éducatif qui ont été beaucoup mis en
doute et dont en fin de compte les
usagers trouvent beaucoup d'intérêt on
voit aussi apparaître une
professionnalisation du périscolaire
avant avant le passage en 4 jours et
demi
on avait en gros le scolaire puis après
trop souvent dans beaucoup d'endroits de
la garderie le fait de dégager
aujourd'hui trois heures de temps péri
éducatif pour tous les élèves nécessite
de se diriger vers davantage de
professionnalisation des intervenants et
on voit aussi émerger le souci de la
cohérence des temps entre le temps
scolaire et le temps périscolaire jeudi
émerger le souci puisque après quelques
mois d'organisation on en est pas à
complètement l'articuler on en est à
voir émerger le souci donc quelques
quelques indications que le se-unsa
souhaiterait voir mettre en oeuvre pour
pour faciliter la mise en oeuvre de
l'arrêt de la réforme dans l'immédiat il
faut que d'abord l'institution continue
d'accompagner la réforme des rythmes
scolaires accompagnés ce qu'ils sont en
train d'imaginer les modes de
fonctionnement pour l'année prochaine
pour qu'ils ne se limite pas et ne
s'interdisent pas des fonctionnements
il faudrait il faudra aussi une fois que
l'organisation du temps scolaire sera
arrêté pour chacune des écoles beaucoup
communiquer en direction des familles
puisque nous avons vu en cette rentrée
qu'en fin de compte les familles ne
s'était pas préparé à ce que
l'organisation de l'école soit nouvelles
soient différentes et donc un difficulté
difficulté à se repérer sur le qui fait
quoi qui est responsable de quoi
il faut donner du temps de concertation
aux équipes dans la période de
construction des projets et
la construction va arriver dans la
période où on va avoir arrêtées bientôt
les horaires scolaires pour autant il va
falloir continuer à beaucoup travailler
sur l'articulation entre les différents
temps les contenus donc il faut il faut
donner du temps aux équipes pour
travailler pour travailler à st il faut
veiller à la qualité du dialogue du
dialogue entre les différents
partenaires
nous encourageons notre institution a
engagée autant que nécessaire les
partenaires à se remettre autour de la
table lorsque parfois il ne s'agit même
pas de désaccord parfois il s'agit de
noms dialogue chacun à travailler dans
son coin la collectivité d'un côté les
enseignants de l'autre souvent
maintenant les familles mais mais on ne
sait pas parler est souvent rien que de
se remettre autour de la table permet de
lever un certain nombre de malentendus
d'opposition supposer qu'ils sont autant
de blocages au moment où il faudra le
mettre en oeuvre à la rentrée
il faut aussi tout à fait soigner les
aspects très pratique
les passages de responsabilité le qui
fait quoi et à quelle heure où est-ce
qu'on inscrit les enfants comment
utilise-t-on les locaux avec le partage
des locaux est il selon quelle charte
entre nous il faut aussi dégager du
temps aux équipes et tout
particulièrement directeur d'école au
moment de la rentrée
le moment de la mise en oeuvre de la
découverte de ce menu de ce nouveau
fonctionnement fait que les enseignants
les directeurs d'école qui sont les
premiers repérés par les familles sont
beaucoup sollicités pour savoir comment
ça marche
ou est ce qu on l'inscrit voit ce qu'on
le récupère et il faut donc que le
directeur d'école à ce moment là soit
libérée d'un maximum des tâches
administratives en tout cas celles qui
peuvent être repoussé un peu plus tard
dans l'année de la part de l'institution
il faut aussi et là nous on s'est
adressé un autre ministère à ce sujet
facilité
l'octroi des temps partiels pour nos
collègues femmes alors hommes et femmes
mais on sait bien que dans notre
profession très féminisée l'organisation
de la vie personnelle l'articulation de
la vie personnelle avec la vie
professionnelle est compliqué donc il
faut pouvoir octroyé facilement des
temps partiels à nos collègues et enfin
il faudra aussi savoir se donner du
temps pour ne pas juger tout de suite
pour regarder les fonctionnements pour
savoir corriger ajusté pour ça il faut
savoir se parler facilement entre les
partenaires à l'oeuvre sur ce sujet et
puis cette réforme d'abord son premier
enjeu c'est qu'elle se met en route et
ensuite on pense pour le se-unsa qu'elle
ouvre de nouvelles portes de nouveaux
espaces sur la cohérence des temps
notamment et que à plus long terme nous
nous reposerons la question de du
pilotage de l'ensemble du temps de
l'enfant à l'école de l'articulation des
différentes interventions et il faudra
sûrement retourner vers les projets
éducatifs territoriaux pour que ceux ci
dépassent leur première étape qui est
souvent seulement une étape assez
formelle pour obtenir des dérogations
pour leur donner davantage corps
davantage vie et qu'on l'on sache aussi
aménager le premier projet qu'on aurait
imaginé par ce que l'on s'apercevra que
ça doit évoluer dans le temps je vous
remercie
merci à vous donc une présentation
souhaité par messieurs patrick roumagnac
et franck mutuel a donc dû syndicat de
l'inspection de l'éducation nationale
madame la présidente madame le
rapporteur mesdames et messieurs les
sénatrices et sénateurs mesdames et
messieurs la réforme des rythmes
scolaires
certes c'est un aspect phare est un
aspect très médiatisée de l'évolution
qui est en place mais ça n'est qu'une
composante de quelque chose de beaucoup
plus ambitieux qui s'appelle la
refondation la refondation de l'école
autrement dit je souhaiterais réinscrire
c'est des observations que je peux faire
dans cette dynamique de la refondation
même si je souscris très largement à ce
qui vient d'être dit par mon collègue
je pense que si on ne rapporte pas à
l'ambition véritablement qui est posé on
risque de se retrouver face à une mesure
qui au bout du compte ne produira
peut-être pas autant d'effet que ce
qu'on pourrait attendre
est ce que il y a quelques années quand
on fonctionnait selon le régime des cinq
matinées en obtenait des résultats
beaucoup plus satisfaisant que ce qu'on
a aujourd'hui ce n'est pas totalement
évident donc il faut probablement que
nous relations la question de la réforme
des rythmes scolaires dans la
perspective plus globale de la
refondation de l'école et dans cette
perspective plus globale
cela veut dire qu'on va devoir donner du
sens donner du sens et reconstruire une
véritable confiance dans l'école
ce qui veut dire qu'il va falloir que
l'école réussisse à convaincre
sage et les parents d'élèves les jeunes
au sens large parce que on a aussi au
fil du temps des élèves qui ont des
positions citoyenne a développé au sein
des établissements scolaires et leurs
écoles l'institution scolaire
il va falloir qu'on réussisse à
reconstruire véritablement cette
relation de confiance
or pour reconstruire cette relation de
confiance je crois qu'aujourd'hui on ne
peut pas se limiter à une relation entre
école et usagers il faut véritablement
qu'on rentre dans une dynamique beaucoup
plus large qui implique les
collectivités territoriales qui implique
les parents d'élèves bien évidemment qui
implique les partenaires de l'école et
l'école pourquoi tout simplement parce
que il ya peut-être quelque chose que
les rythmes scolaires vont nous aider à
comprendre et commencent déjà à
s'amorcer
c'est le fait qu'il n'y a pas de
séparation entre un enfant et un élève
si ce n'est une séparation totalement
illusoire on a vécu trop longtemps sur
l'idée selon laquelle un enfant à partir
du moment où il arrivait à l'école
devenez un élève s'est complètement
illusoire
ça reste un enfant qui a toute sa vie
qui a tous ses attaches qui a tous ces
problèmes toutes ces difficultés qui
quand il va rentrer chez lui le soir a
aussi et ramène à la maison toutes les
difficultés qu'il a pu vivre à l'école
et on se doit se retrouver véritablement
une nécessaire continuité et c'est
peut-être ça que les rythme vont nous
apprendre ils vont nous apprendre à
gérer non plus une vision morcelé d'un
enfant mais une vision beaucoup plus
globale une vision beaucoup plus globale
dans lesquels dans laquelle chacun des
partenaires à un regard équivalent à
l'autre n'ont pas équivalent au sens 2
c'est le même mais équivalent au sens de
il a la même valeur
le regard d'un animateur dans le cadre
des travaux pédagogiques dehors du temps
scolaire des travaux périscolaire a
autant d'importance que le regard d'un
enseignant a autant d'importance que le
regard d'un parent
a autant d'importance que le regard que
l'enfant va pouvoir au fil du temps
faire passer progressivement vers ces
différentes personnes donc on a
véritablement un enjeu de grande
complexité
le problème serait de considérer
aujourd'hui que la modification des
rythmes scolaires suffit à apporter une
réponse qui permettra une meilleure
réussite de tous les élèves
si la réponse était aussi simple
franchement on peut espérer qu'elle a
longtemps qu'on aurait trouvé si on
n'est pas aujourd'hui en mesure d'aider
autant qu'on le souhaiterait tous les
élèves à mieux réussir à l'école c'est
probablement que la réponse est beaucoup
plus ambitieuse est beaucoup plus
complexe qu'une simple adaptation des
temps scolaires qui par ailleurs
disons le à l'heure actuelle pose un
certain nombre de difficultés qui ont
été très largement soulignée par mon
collègue
comment est-ce qu'on peut traiter cette
complexité
en fait la loi de refondation elle-même
inclut le dispositif qui permet de
traiter cette difficulté c'est le fameux
pe d'été le fameux projet éducatif
territorial qui doit associer tous les
partenaires n'ont pas privilégier les
uns par rapport aux autres n'ont pas
dire à l'école à vous de le faire ou aux
collectivités à vous de gérer mais dans
une dynamique de co-construction
effectivement des politiques éducatives
donc où il va falloir que chacun
participe ensemble et apporte
spécificités de son regard pour une
meilleure réussite de tous les jeunes et
cpe d'été le paradoxe c'est qu'à l'heure
actuelle ils ne sont pas obligatoires ou
plus précisément ils ne sont
obligatoires que sur les opérations
extrêmement formel on l'a dit tout à
l'heure le pe d'été est obligatoire
quand il y à dérogation au temps
scolaire classique il est obligatoire
quand il y à dérogation au taux
d'encadrement
donc chaque fois qu'on a à faire à
quelque chose qui est quelque chose de
ponctuel vous rend obligatoire mais par
contre on ne lui donne pas son sens
son ampleur sa véritable portée et je
crois que c'est sûrement une des
priorités pour nous à l'heure actuelle
c'est de creuser cette question des
projets éducatifs territoriaux et de
faire que on en face de véritables
outils de pilotage
quand on parle d'outils de pilotage ça
veut dire qu'on va devoir intégrer dans
la ces questions des pays endettés
véritablement tout ce qui va faciliter
la mise en oeuvre de l'ambition
territoriale par rapport à tous les
jeunes et on sait que selon les
territoires
cette ambition va être extrêmement
complexe a porté selon constitue dans un
milieu urbain sensibles ou dans un
milieu urbain plus confortable où selon
constitue dans un milieu rural et loyers
en milieu de montagne par exemple on va
se retrouver dans des situations
totalement différente
comment pourrions nous imaginer que dans
des situations aussi différente on
puisse arriver à proposer des réponses
formelle qui soit satisfaisante pour
tous et en tout lieu
ça n'a aucun sens ce qui veut dire
qu'aujourd'hui ce qui est déterminant
c'est la souplesse qu'on sera capable de
mettre dans le dispositif et non pas
l'autoritarisme le formalisme que
l'institution sera capable d'imaginer
pour finalement neutralisées tout ce qui
serait de l'ordre de l'initiative locale
de l'initiative une collectivité
territoriale de l'initiative d'une
équipe d'enseignants je crois qu'il faut
vraiment aujourd'hui
laissez un espace de confiance et laissé
et faciliter l'émergence de ces projets
très difficile de faciliter l'émergence
d'un projet quand on dit à ceux qui
doivent rédiger le projet vous n'oubliez
pas qu'il doit être bouclé pour telle
date et que une fois qu'il aura été
approuvé et ben voilà il continuera sur
son r c'est très difficile qu'est ce qui
va se passer si un des animateurs n'est
plus disponible
le projet est toujours imaginé en
fonction d'un contexte et le contexte
évolue donc ça veut dire qu'il faut
permettre une véritable souplesse dans
le fonctionnement de ces projets et
l'accompagnement que les inspecteurs
sont en mesure de mettre en place c'est
un accompagnement qui doit se concevoir
dans cette dynamique de souplesse et
d'adaptation
pas dans une dynamique de contrôle et de
normes à l'heure actuelle les normes les
contrôles sont sûrement des éléments
importants quand il évite des dérives ça
peut aussi devenir des éléments
extrêmement inhibant par rapport aux
ambitions qui sont ceux du système la
loi d'orientation la loi d'orientation
pour la refondation portant refondation
de l'école est une loi d'ambition
si nous argue boutons sur des éléments
de contrôle au lieu de véritablement
accompagner cette ambition il y a fort
peu de chances que nous avancions
réellement les inspecteurs sont prêts à
rentrer dans cette dynamique ils l'ont
montré dans le cadre des relations
qu'ils ont entretenue avec les
collectivités territoriales et dans
toutes les lieux où les collectivités
ont sollicité systématiquement les
inspecteurs se sont largement attaché à
faciliter les choses il faut que nous
continuions dans cette dynamique et que
résolument nous mettions en place les
souplesse nécessaire pour que la loi
portent véritablement toutes ses
ambitions et pour que ses ambitions
soient au service de tous les jeunes
voilà simplement ce que je dirai en
préambule merci infiniment toutes ces
présentations sont très complémentaires
à présent la parole est à monsieur
frédéric sève secrète pardon oui si
secrétaire général du syndicat général
de l'éducation nationale cfdt qui est
accompagné de monsieur joël bon enfant
secrétaire général national sepa grand
bonjour et merci madame la présidente
madame le rapporteur et messieurs dames
les sénateurs alors sur pour répondre à
vos de vous de demande d'abord un une
forme de bilan forcément partiel
provisoire de l'application d'une
réforme qui est elle même partielle et
provisoire
je dirais je reprendrai d'ailleurs des
éléments qui viennent d'être dit par mes
deux collègues je dirais que c'est une
réforme qui était absolument nécessaire
je veux dire d'ailleurs elle était dans
l'air depuis quelques temps j'ai tout le
monde s'attendait est compris dans le
milieu éducatif à ce qu'effectivement on
revienne sur la somme de 4 jours on
passe alors sur des modalités qui
restent est évidemment à définir mais
cette évolution ne faisait de ne poser
question pour personne la question de
savoir effectivement quand et comment on
la mettra en place réformes nécessaires
mais réforme effectivement je reprendrai
parfaitement enfin totalement ce cas
d'une flore ou manyaka l'instant réforme
pas en soi suffisante
bien entendu c'est un élément déjà six
mois son côté nécessaire il fallait
lever ce verrou des temps scolaires qui
pénalise les apprentissages des élèves
je me permet quand même de citer puisque
j'ai dit que ça n'était pas suffi ça
n'est pas suffisant il ya d'autres
éléments nécessaires à une meilleure
réussite scolaire laissez-moi site et ou
même la formation et plus
particulièrement la formation continue
puisque la formation initiale bon on est
en phase de reconstruction
on a tout de même aussi le besoin de
reconstruire une formation continue et
là je dirais on est beaucoup plus loin
du port on n'est pas encore arrivé à
tout ça pour dire que on est
effectivement face à quelque chose de
nécessaire mais quelque chose encore une
fois de pas définitif et ne pas
suffisant alors pourquoi nécessaire ça a
été dit là encore en substance
l'essentiel était de redonner du de
dégager du temps utile pour apprendre je
le dirai comme ça de faire que dans la
semaine dans le temps scolaire des
élèves il y ait plus de temps utile pour
les apprentissages
ça suppose une meilleure de prendre en
compte
globalement les temps de l'enfant qui
effectivement ne cesse pas d'être un
enfant quand il rentre à l'école ne
cesse pas d'être un élève quand il en
sort c'est parfaitement exact mais fait
donc avoir une vision cohérente et je
veux dire je dirais qu'il fallait
surtout réaliser cette articulation des
temps de l'enfant dans la journée plutôt
que dans la semaine
ce qu'on peut reprocher à la semaine de
quatre jours c'est justement d'avoir 10
bat pour articuler les choses le plus
simple c'est de se partager les jours
lundi mardi jeudi vendredi pour l'école
le mercredi le samedi le dimanche pour
la famille et d'autres et tous les
autres acteurs non la semaine de
l'enfant de se
écoute pas en journée homogène c'est la
journée qu'il faut prendre en charge et
derrière au delà d'ailleurs delà de
l'impact éducatif il ya bien si un
impact j'ai presque envie d'air sociétal
même si ça peut paraître un grand mot
sait on est au bois on est au début
peut-être on en cours de la construction
d'un service global de l'accueil
éducatif des enfants je crois que c'est
ça qui est en jeu dire comment la
société prend en charge l'éducation des
enfants et comment elle arrive à
articuler les différents rôles éducatif
que peuvent être ceux des enseignants
ceux des parents ceux des associations
soient enfin bref ceux de la société
entière donc il y avait effectivement
que je nécessité on savait que ça laisse
faire on savait qu'il fallait avancer
alors cela dit effectivement cette
réforme a rencontré susciter des
problèmes on va surtout pas le nier
puisque effectivement nous avons été aux
premières en première loge je commandais
parmi les premiers réceptacle de ses
difficultés
je leur ai tenté d expliquer rapidement
rapidement j'ai essayé de les expliquer
pas trop longuement on va dire la
première tout de même c'est que cette
réforme est arrivé dans un contexte
particulier et notamment celui d'une
profession les professeurs d'école
particulièrement ne sais pas comment
dire
ce coût est mise à mal interpellés ces
dernières années et quand je dis ces
dames a donné d'ailleurs je ne rêvais
pas aux cinq dernières années n'ont pas
la mandature précédente
c'est effectivement une profession qui
cessantes qui se sent toujours
d'ailleurs mal aimés minerai mal
considérés dans le système éducatif pour
toutes sortes de raisons que je ne pas
ouvrir maintenant faire un peu long mais
il ya un sentiment d'inéquité traitement
très fort chez nos collègues du premier
degré qui fait que chaque nouvelle
réforme devient cristallise en quelque
sorte qu'on pense à c'est un premier
élément et tant qu'on n'aura pas régler
fondamentalement cette question d'une
équité ou lui même même si on peut
considérer que ce n'est qu'un sentiment
d'inéquité je pense quant à moi que ça
n'est pas qu'un sentiment qu'il ya une
réalité d'un traitement inéquitable du
premier degré mais il faudra le traité
il faudra surmonter ça pour avancer
durablement nature n'importe quelle
réforme du premier degré de ça il ya un
élément à prendre en compte
ensuite cette réforme plus concrètement
à poser des problèmes je dirais de mise
en oeuvre
alors stéphane crochet à la cité
quelques-uns le transfert de
responsabilités le partage des classes
il ya plein de petits problèmes compte
le partage des salles de classe où le
dire il ya plein de petits problèmes
concrets qui sont quand je dis petit je
veux pas dire par là qu'ils sont sans
importance au contraire qui serait
révèle cruciaux pour le pour la mise en
place de ces rythmes scolaires et qui
sont souvent le facteur déterminant d'un
conflit autour du passage du retour à la
semaine de quatre jours et demi
simplement de remarques ces problèmes
sont extrêmement divers d'abord dans la
nature j'en ai cité 2 mai la liste et
est long comme un jour sans pain est
extrêmement divers dans leur intensité
d'une école d'une commune à l'autre
donc n'en faisons pas une unité plus
exactement je dire par là qu'on ne peut
pas généraliser le traitement enfin la
solution ne peut pas être général j'ai
clarifié un tout petit que nos propos
dans ce qui nous guette cfdt nous a
préoccupé ces derniers ces dernières
mois autour des propos de la querelle
des rythmes scolaires c'est que on
partait notre problème concret réel qui
est relevé de la mise en oeuvre de la
réforme des quatre jours et demi
auquel on essaie de donner une solution
nationale général uniforme qui était la
rediscussion le report le déplacement
d'une virgule du décret relative à la
semaine scolaire là à notre avis la
raison majeure qui fait que ce dossier
peut paraître notre avis ne l'est pas
mais peut paraître dans l'ornière
c'est l'incapacité qu'ont à organiser un
dialogue social qui permet de traiter
les problèmes là où il se pose à
l'échelon il se pose
la difficulté c'est fitoussi si
effectivement il ya des problèmes pour
savoir comment transférer organiser le
passage de 30 passage d'un groupe
d'élèves d'un enseignant un personnel
municipal - intervenants extérieurs
il ya effectivement des primes comme de
gens là j'espère bien que jamais c'est
un décret du ministère des questions
nationales qui réglera cela en question
on ne peut pas il ya aussi cette c'est
l'autre élément d'explication que je
voulais arriver c'est cette incapacité
qu'on a et quand je dis on je m'inclus
jeu nous inclus nos organisations
syndicales dedans a résonné à propos des
questions éducatives au niveau local au
niveau territorial au niveau adapté mais
obtint la tendance à tout ramener au
niveau national et à tout exiger à tout
vouloir régler par une construction une
solution nationale ce qui est notre
allié un strictement impossible et deux
complètement trop
contre-productif face à chaque fois
qu'on prétend régler un problème par une
règle nationale
eh bien on en crée 15 autres parce
qu'elle est pas adapté à d'autres
situations
je m'appuierai d'ailleurs pour renforcer
le même propos sur les exemples de
réussite parce que même dans les 20 25 %
de communes qui sont passés à quatre
jours et demi qui sont revenus à quatre
jours et demi certaines d'ailleurs en
anticipant la réforme pour dire qu'il ya
bien eu une demande
j'ose le dire dans ces communes vient
très souvent on ça quand on les a quand
on analyse le processus de construction
du retour à la semaine de quatre jours
et demi s'aperçoit qu'il n'a toujours eu
quand ça réussit un dialogue une
concertation très approfondies en amont
parfois très longues parfois un an avant
pour celles qui sont passés avant celle
que je souhaite que l'on fait dans la
fouille de la réforme le délai a
forcément été un peu plus court il ya
bien ça ça souligne encore une fois que
ce dialogue social cette concertation
est une condition de la réussite
alors ça me donne ça nous donnera je le
développe un type bien sûr une des
préconisations d'une gaine cfdt qui est
de s'assurer de se donner les moyens
d'un vrai dialogue social de qualité
dans l'école ce qui n'est pas gagné
j'y reviens dans un instant cela dit
avant je voudrais pointe et d'autres
choses
il ya tout de même sur le dossier des
rythmes scolaires eux mêmes en tant que
tel il ya tout de même nécessité à notre
avis d'approfondir je vais reprendre un
terme un peu soft et et approfondir la
réflexion mais je pense qu'il faut aller
plus loin nous pensions qu'il faut aller
plus loin
pourquoi d'abord je ne pensons que la
journée il faut trouver les moyens pour
que la journée soit encore un peu plus
petite la journée de stricte
apprentissage afin d'être journée
scolaire proprement dit doit être
réduite encore il faut aussi se poser la
question de la différenciation des âges
mes collègues ont très justement
souligné la distinction qu'il est
nécessaire d'opérer entre l'école
maternelle et l'école élémentaire
mais il faut aller aussi plus loin et
c'est même à l'inter de l'école
élémentaire un élève de cp n'a pas les
mêmes capacités d'apprentissage qu'un
élève de cm2 est donc cette idée que ne
l'est encore qui relève un peu de nos
espèces demi d'uniformité que tous les
élèves doivent avoir le même nombre
d'heures de classe dans l'année
elle est aussi contre-productive va
falloir un jour l'interroger
faut raisonner aussi pourquoi pas sur
l'année scolaire se demander si le
calendrier annuel va être un élément
aussi intégré à la réflexion
enfin pour notamment éviter de donner
l'impression que la question ne se pose
que dans le premier degré et que donc ne
concerne que les collègues du premier
degré étant la réflexion au second degré
il ya aussi un problème de rythme
scolaire il ya aussi des d une réflexion
à mener sur les rythmes scolaires au
niveau des collèges et des lycées
je me permets juste de pointer pour dire
je pas sectaires de pointer le tralala
le travail là la campagne de
communication est en train de faire
l'une lunel l'union nationaliste
injustement pour demander une meilleure
prise en compte de meilleur meilleure
organisation des rythmes scolaires au
lycée
donc la question est bien plus générale
et je pense aussi qu on facilitera son
traitement dans le premier degré quand
on a traitera de façon générale deuxième
deux paquets de préconisations il ya
aussi une oeuvre
je dirais une ingénierie on le sent bien
de nous qui participeront au comité de
suivi de la réforme des rythmes
scolaires
on sent bien qu'il ya besoin entre les
communes sont pas toujours j'allais dire
outillés n'ont pas toujours spontanément
les ressources qui leur permettent de
mettre en place ce genre de réforme et
là il ya un besoin de construire un
d'alimenter de partager l'ingénérie ça
se fait déjà ça s'organise j'imagine par
les associations de maires de france
mais moi il ya des moyens mais
manifestement il faut travailler à ça et
je me permets de si je le relève c'est
aussi que ça me permet de souligner une
difficulté qu'on retrouve nous acteurs
de l'éducation nationale enfin
syndicales de l'éducation nationale dans
d'autres dossiers
c'est que on est confronté en france
aujourd'hui excusez moi à l'organisation
de un problème de collaboration entre
entités publiques différentes dire que
la décentralisation est entré dans les
moeurs mais c'était une décentralisation
vous m'excuserez si j'osais caricature
séparation chacun ses compétences et
chacun les traite dans son coin
or on s'aperçoit que beaucoup d'objets
l'éducation en est un demande au
contraire que les acteurs coopèrent et
que chacun à partir de ses compétences
travail à un même objectif et ça c'est
pas toujours facile
là clairement on l'a sur l'éducation les
rythmes scolaires qui demandent de faire
travailler l'état demain de faire
travailler les communes
et puis même à l'intérieur de l'état
peut-être parfois tous les échelons du
système qu'ils sont
toujours forcément très cohérents entre
eux je dis pas ça pour jeter la pierre à
qui que ce soit mais bon une grosse
machine comme l'éducation nationale a
aussi des besoins de coordination qui
sont pas évidents soi et 7/10 mandat
dimension de coordination entre acteurs
publics
je pense qu'on est au début des choses
et puis alors j'en reviens à ma notre
revendication fondamentale c'est la
dimension du dialogue social alors joue
pas redire ce que j'ai dit tout à
l'heure mais je voudrais souligner deux
conséquences de cela alors d'abord une
exigence avant les conséquences de cette
ce besoin de dialogue social
une exigence et quand j'ai dit dialogue
social bien que je sois syndicats qui en
l'occurrence pour le dossier qui nous
concerne nous indiquent les enseignants
je pense qu'il faut quand je parle des
aides sociales j'entends bien dialogue
social avec les enseignants mais avec
tous les personnels qui travaillent à
l'école c'était les personnes municipaux
les intervenants extérieurs surtout
syndiqués alors à des fédérations
différentes de la cfdt mais c'est bien
les collectifs de travail avec lesquels
il faut discuter et pas les corps
séparés et se scissionner les uns des
autres
donc ça c'est une exigence particulière
cela dit ça pose deux questions plus
plus crucial la première c'est
effectivement là les deux d'ailleurs
sont à sont associés la première c'est
la place de directeur d'école
effectivement les directeurs de fête
joue un rôle aujourd'hui qui ne
correspondaient largement comment dire
surdimensionné par rapport à la la
considération la fonction la posture que
locke que leur donne les textes
réglementaires
les directeurs sont positionnés dans une
suite je dire aussi on veut être le plus
aux tests sont de fait des animateurs
des clips mais en fait si on aime
beaucoup plus ils sont le responsable de
l'école soit à l'intersection de tous
ces acteurs consiste à quoi il faut
rajouter les familles donc il n ya
besoin de reconsidérer ce rôle
effectivement de le professionnaliser et
bien de considérer qu'un directeur est
d'abord un directeur c'est par un
enseignant qui fait des tâches de
direction mais c'est bien le directeur
qui parfois à des tâches de
d'enseignement mais que c'est bien sûr
cette fonction-là la direction de ce
soir à des tâches c'est un métier il
faut le dire il faut les traiter en
conséquence ce sont des animateurs sont
des responsables sont pas des chaînons
administratif ou hiérarchie
et deuxième chose
il faut étendre pratiquement la même
réflexion mais à l'école toute entière à
notre avis une inde et en tout cas ce
que révèle cette affaire des rythmes
scolaires mais pas seulement cette
affaire-là
c'est la carence de personnes juridiques
de personnalité juridique de l'école
l'école juridiquement n'existe pas à
l'école n'est n'est pas un établissement
n'est pas fan a pas de personnages
aldric effectivement du coup tout se
décide tout ce qui concerne les colts se
décide en dehors de l'école est donc
loin du collectif de travail quand je
dis collective travail j'incite en corse
et les enseignants et les autres et donc
tant qu'on n'aura pas résolu cette
question là alors je peux importe la
forme
peu importe la façon mais tant qu'on
n'aura pas réintégré redonner de la
personnalité à l'école est donc redonné
au collet qui travaillent la possibilité
d'agir sur la marche de l'école papa
contre leur hiérarchie pas contre la
municipalité pas contre le reste du
monde
mais pour leur part tant qu'on n'aura
pas donné dit que concrètement on leur
donne un espace d'intervention n'est ce
pas 2009
mon but sera sans cesse sur des preuves
de ce genre là dans la réforme de
l'enseignement primaire
voilà je vous remercie je m'excuse si
j'ai été un peu longue j'avais mis ma
montre mais je n'ai pas regardé
donc on est on est tout à fait dans les
temps je remercie infiniment donc les
nos derniers intervenants messieurs
bruno lamour secrétaire général de la
fédération formation et enseignement
privé c'est l'été et monsieur à la de
boot secrétaire national qu'il assiste
alors juste tout à l'heure pour rendre à
césar ce qui appartient à césar monsieur
bon enfant et secrétaire national
merci madame la présidente donc mesdames
la présidente et rapporteur mesdames et
messieurs les sénateurs
mesdames et messieurs eux je vais le
dire tout de go la fep cfdt comme les
autres collègues s'est engagé
favorablement pour enfin voir ça pour la
pour la réforme et notre discours est
constant depuis des mois donc je vais
dire que globalement pour le dire
rapidement
nous sommes tout à fait d'accord avec
les constats qui viennent d'être
présentés d'accord aussi sur les
difficultés qu'ils sont repérés même si
pour nous elles sont un peu spécifique
je vais y revenir
j'ajouterai juste que par rapport au
contexte je crois que nous on faisait le
constat que nos collègues ont quand même
été sacrément usées si je peux utiliser
cette expression par des années un peu
de flottement
c'est le féminisme et ce sentiment je le
dis à ma façon
on veut bien changer l'école mais sans
nous laissez nous tranquilles donc
évidemment c'est une petite difficulté à
vaincre
bon on s'y emploie bon ce petit
préliminaire pour dire que j'ai pas de
façon nous n'avons pas de façon
originale par rapport à nos collègues
qui viennent de s'exprimer de présenter
et les constats ou les bienfaits de la
réforme et les difficultés de repérer
long je vais me concentrer sur la
situation particulière de l'enseignement
privé se comptera en fait notre problème
on a grosso modo 5300 écoles privées bon
c'est papa très très claires sous
contrat je ne sais pas exactement ce qui
est sûr c'est que on parle beaucoup dans
notre pays de l'enseignement catholique
et j'irais là à juste titre puisque
c'est quand même la grosse part du
marché 4717 école donc près la
proportion aujourd'hui sur ces écoles on
parlera pas les autres parce qu on ne
repère pas bien ce qui s'y passe c'est à
dire dans les autres réseaux
confessionnelle ou réseau laïque et dans
l'enseignement catholique on a moins de
10% qui se sont tant des écoles qui se
sont engagés en fait à la rentrée 2013
dans la réforme et même si peut-être
qu'on va être exagérément pessimiste on
craint que à la rentrée 2014 la
proportion ne s'accroisse pas énormément
voilà alors pourquoi pourquoi basse et
c'est assez simple à notre sens il ya
une une raison qui est essentiel c'est
que un établissement sous contrat en
fait n'est pas tenue de mettre en place
la réforme pour des raisons
réglementaires
on pourra en discuter ça c'est pas
j'irai le problème ce qui est certain
c'est ce que cela génère par conséquence
entrer de manière très claire un chef
d'établissement aujourd'hui en 2014 2015
2016 peut tout à fait le faire le choix
de rester à quatre jours ce qui veut
dire que nos difficultés nous essentiel
ou spécifiques
elle réside dans cette nonne application
obligatoire de la réforme toutes les
autres raisons que l'on à repérer en
terme de difficulté je pense nous
pensions découle de cette raison
essentielle alors les autres raisons je
les cite rapidement on a des frilosités
évidemment félicité parce qu'on craint
par exemple que la nouvelle organisation
qui seraient mises en place face
les familles donc on peut même se
retrancher derrière des enquêtes à peu
près fabriqué pour simplement arriver au
constat qu'on ne peut absolument pas
mettre la réforme en place parce que les
plaies les parents d'élèves sont contre
on a des témoignages dans ce sens y
compris des écrits on a des paris sur
l'avenir qui à notre sens sont non
fondées mais qui ont quand même cours
dans les écoles
c'est à dire que le pari est fait que la
réforme dans ce non publique fera des
mécontents et que donc les crew on
récupérera des familles ça existe
là on n'a pas de témoignages écrits
n'avons que des propos tenus dans les
établissements on a aussi des refus par
principe d'entrée tout simplement dans
un dispositif municipal est bon on a
aussi bien sûr des relations tendues et
difficiles mais vous connaissez le
contexte de notre pays entre les deux
secteurs donc des des relations tendues
entre les établissements et les
municipalités et je veux dire là pour
être honnête que le problème ne vient
pas que des établissements sous montre
ce serait trop simple de dire que ce
sont les établissements sous contrat qui
bien sûr ont fermé leurs portes aux
municipalités n'ont à ce jeu là si c'est
un jeu c'est bien les deux acteurs qui à
un moment donné en fonction des
départements
ça peut être soit l'enseignement privé
l'enseignement catholique soit les
municipalités et puis retrouve raison il
y en a certainement d'autres
ce qu on entend assez souvent fonds
d'amorçage jugé insuffisant mais c'est
souvent quand même un prétexte pour ne
pas s'engager
ça je là aussi je j'ai c'est d'être
honnête sur ce point alors les
conséquences c'est bien les conséquences
c'est que les craintes et les
résistances je l' ai dit tout à l'heure
des personnels sont sensiblement les
mêmes que celles qui ont été repérés par
nos collègues du public que donc je vais
je vais faire court mais du coup ils
sont peu enclins à défend à défendre la
réforme et défaut en plus d'engagement
de leur établissement ne peut que les
satisfaire ce qui veut dire que pour
nous continuez à défendre
dans ces conditions le bien fondé de la
réforme est quand même une épreuve un
peu difficile et c'est vrai que on se
pose souvent la question de savoir
combien de temps on pourra tenir parce
que on a l'impression parfois de ramer à
contre-courant bien évidemment même si
après lors des dialogues que l'on peut
avoir est que les personnels on arrive à
convaincre et à leur faire dire que
peut-être beaucoup des difficultés
exposés sont du pur fantasme
d'autant plus que il ya quand même un
certain nombre de points de la réforme
et de ses aspects réglementaires qui ne
sont pas directement applicable aux
enseignants se compteront donc quand on
arrive à ce type de dialogue
je pense qu'on arrive à convaincre mais
bon c'est pas c'est pas si simple que ça
puis à cela ce sur se surajoute le fait
que nous ne sommes pas associés nous va
j'en profite pour le dire dans dans
cette audition comme nos collègues du
public c'est un regret constant aux
travaux préparatoires ce qui fait que
pour une organisation organisation comme
la nôtre qui se dit réformiste qui a un
travail de d'information et de
préparation des esprits si vous me
permettez cette expression
eh bien on est dans l'incapacité de
faire ce travail
ce qui veut dire que à courir après les
trains nos collègues sont plus sensibles
à ce qu ils peuvent entendre par exemple
par rapport aux médias enfin aux médias
ou aux détracteurs de la réforme plutôt
que à un discours de la fep cfdt qui
essaie de leur expliquer que cette
réforme était nécessaire et qu' il faut
aussi enneigés
alors un dernier point c'est la
situation dans les écoles qui ont mis en
oeuvre puisque sans avoir la prétention
de dire qu'on a des chiffres qui sont
infaillibles
on a quand même quelques statistiques
lorsqu'on constate dans les écoles qui
ont mis en oeuvre les réformes et bien
c'est que beaucoup d'enseignants
s'accordent pour dire que oui
au niveau des apprentissages même s'ils
sont très prudents et je crois qu'il
faut l'être parce que nous ne sommes
qu'au tout début de la réforme
et bien il y a effectivement le mot
apaisée a été prononcé tout à l'heure
tout à l'heure il ya une petite heure
une collègue me disais exactement là une
chose on constate à cette rentrée pour
de les écoles qui ont mis en place sa
réforme
une situation qui est beaucoup plus
apaisé et en termes d'apprentissage
on pense que ça peut avoir des effets
bénéfiques donc c'est ce qui est mis en
avant
donc ça c'est intéressant bien sûr pour
nous de faire connaître ce témoignage où
ces témoignages aux écoles qui sont pas
encore entrés dans la réforme
évidemment par rapport aux personnels
quand on les interroge sur leurs
conditions de travail ou leur vie
personnelle là le discours doit être un
petit peu autres il ya effectivement des
effets qui sont j'irai un peu plus
négatifs mais qui bien souvent sont le
fait en fait de ce qui s'est passé au
moment où la réforme s'est mise en place
ce qu'on constate et mon collègue parler
du dialogue social en fait ce qu'on
constate c'est que beaucoup
d'organisations de dans l'est dans les
écoles donc les 10%
qui donc se sont engagés à la réforme
beaucoup d'organisations ont été le fait
du chef d'établissement voir chez nous
d'un directeur diocésain donc on va dire
eux
sur la même territoire qu'un gaz n est
pas des personnels ce qui veut dire
qu'ensuite les difficultés elles ne
peuvent pas être assumés puisque les
gens non n'ont pas eu cette impression
d'avoir été associée à la mise en place
de la nouvelle organisation dans leur
école voilà merci merci beaucoup
j'aimerais pour un maire sans remercier
tous pour ses interventions transversale
mais surtout complémentaires qui nous
donneront lieu à présent un débat un
échange avec les parlementaires avec les
sénateurs si vous en êtes d'accord
madame messieurs nous procédons comme
d'habitude au questionnement qui vous
seront posées par madame le rapporteur
questionnements auxquels vous pourrez
répondre immédiatement
et ensuite nous prendrons une série de
questions de plusieurs sénateurs avec
les réponses de chacun d'entre vous en
fonction d'eux des questions qui vous
seront directement adressés ou parce que
vous vous sentez interpellé voilà donc
madame le rapporteur merci madame la
présidente
et merci d'abord à tous les intervenants
parce que vous avez été très complet et
et au fur et à mesure des questions que
l'on pouvait se poser
vous avez anticipé quelques réponses que
l'on attendait alors un petit point
d'humour d'abord je crois que c'est
l'unsa qui a fait état d'une grande
féminisation de l'école et nous ne
retrouvons pas dans la représentation
que nous avons en face de nous mais
c'était le point pour détendre un petit
peu l'atmosphère
voilà mais j'ai dit vous nous avez vous
nous avez fait un rapport souvent très
complet alors moi j'ai j'ai à la fois
pardo contre le faire alors ici on
compense
alors d'abord je pense d'abord il ya
quelque chose qui vous est commun c'est
que vous partagez tous le bien fondé de
cette réforme
en ne tombant pas dans le piège et ça on
l'a bien compris que ce n'est pas
l'alpha et l'oméga de la refondation de
l'école tant attendu que c'est une étape
une condition mais qu' il y à beaucoup
d'autres a continué à mettre en place et
que c'est vrai sans doute le système
médiatique a beaucoup focalisé sur ce
sur ses propositions au détriment sans
doute d'autres donc ça c'était pour nous
c'est rassurant de voir que les
objectifs affichés
vous écrivez et vous il ya des rires je
crois que dans ce qui est décrit vous
l'avez décrit tous au travers de cette
réforme des rythmes
c'est une vraie révolution culturelle
que doit se livrer la maison éducation
nationale alors cette révolution
culturelle parce que c'est désormais
dire que ce que l'on propose à l'enfant
est un projet global partagé par
différents partenaires et ça alors sur
le terrain c'est très inégale
comme vous l'avait dit il ya des
endroits où il ya déjà le dialogue qui
est en place il y en a d'autres où on
est encore close au nez et là je crois
que l'éducation nationale un grand rôle
à jouer pour ça que je me tourne vers
les inspecteurs parce que certes puis
j'y reviendrai après au directeur
d'école mais certes il ya parfois des
alors je dirais des situations un peu
figé qui tiennent à l'histoire et qui
tiennent à des années des années de
fonds aujourd'hui on demande de
bousculer et je crois qu'il ya les deux
parties qui ont besoin d'être
accompagnés jeudi les deux parties c'est
à dire les enseignants parce qu'ils sont
aujourd'hui encore dans un
fonctionnement une représentation pour
certaines
et les mairies qui se trouve avec un
projet sur les bras à construire pour
lesquels il y en a qui sont très démunis
et plus que là je crois que vous nous
avez évoqué les associations de maires
et autres les mairies demande enfin je
pense à l'éducation nationale de les
accompagner parce qu'au sein de ce
projet éducatif territorial ya le mot
éducatif et que quand même aujourd'hui
comme partout on fait confiance à
l'éducation nationale pour la qualité de
ce qu'elle peut proposer aux enfants
donc moi je jose voilà jeu sur le
terrain c'est très inégale l'implication
des des inspecteurs très inégale et je
vois là j'entre et faire passer ce
message et vous demandez comment alors
est ce que bon vous avez un manque de
personnel est ce que vous avez aussi
beaucoup d'autres charges qui vous
accapare mais est-ce que vous
réfléchissez au niveau des inspecteurs à
une évolution de votre métier est
justement la manière de l'exercer
ça c'était une première question
la deuxième question la révolution
culturelle c'est aussi cette réflexion
pour les inspecteurs c'est un peu de
terre passer d'une culture de l'ordre et
de l'injonction à une culture de
l'imagination de l'innovation et de la
souplesse
là aussi comment peut se faire cet cette
évolution culturelle ensuite injustement
quand vous posez la place ce qui est
réel la place éminente du directeur
d'école ou de l'école en filigrane alors
je vous dois d'aller plus loin vous
poser le problème du statut du directeur
et de l'évolution du statut des écoles
voilà donc est-ce que voilà est ce que
dans votre réflexion vous aller jusque
là et avec moi laquelle je veux dire
quel modèle nouveau pour le statut de
le statut de directeur d'école enfin
vous avez posée puisque c'est vrai que
ce n'est qu'un premier pas et on adhère
c'est enfin moi j'adhère à 7 à cette
idée qu'on ne peut pas faire pour les
enfants de maternelle de primaire quel
que soit le niveau la même proposition
est-ce que vous avez réfléchi est ce que
vous pensez qu'il est possible de
moduler les heures d'enseignement et de
faire je sais que dans certains pays
européens
les enfants de cp non pas autant
d'heures d'enseignement que les enfants
de cm1 cm2 est-ce que là aussi ce
chantier est ouvert au travers de cette
réforme des re in et est ce que vous y
avez réfléchi est-ce qu'on est ce qu'on
peut aller est-ce qu'on peut aller plus
loin et puis le dernier point je voulais
m'adresser aux représentants
l'enseignement privé
quand vous dites que vous n'êtes pas
associés c'est au niveau du ministère
première question
deuxième question il y avait un travail
de conviction à faire et de pédagogie
et ça ça a été dit par un des
intervenants et enfin moi je pense aussi
qu'il ya eu qu un défaut de
communication auprès des parents pour
expliquer le pourquoi mais sans doute
ça passe aussi dans l'enseignement privé
par le rôle du directeur puisque le
projet quand même est très élaborée dans
l'enseignement privé donc comment
imaginez vous une bonne communication
pour que l'on puisse susciter l'adhésion
autour de ce qui aujourd'hui fait
consensus chez tous ceux qui
réfléchissent un as à l'enfant et quelle
forme
pensez-vous vers quelle forme devrions
nous aller pour étant allée qui doit
porter aussi cette communication pour
être légitime
voilà vous avez donc pu suivre la suite
des auditions de la mission
d'information sur la réforme des rythmes
scolaires tout de suite
24 ans et n'a présenté par delphine
girard